hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on apex legends again
and today we have some interesting news
to talk about a new leak was found again
to the data mines and the data files
about two new weapons that are possibly
coming to the game and fans of titanfall
might actually be really appreciative of
what these weapons are so as always
liked tivity if you do enjoy subscriber
her new I cover the informational side
of apex legends that being the balance
changes the new the new heroes the new
legends the new leaks all the type of
stuff so if you want to be caught up
today with everything happening in the
world of apex legends they Stephan
atleast a subscribe to the channel and
with that let's get started so to get a
few things out of the way real quick I
do apologize for my voice I woke up
about two minutes ago it's about 12:30
when I'm recording this I should have
been up like three hours before that but
I don't care about to sleep in too much
as always credit to gaming Intel the
guys have been very helpful if you do
want to check the link in the
description that'll be the source to
this website that I took it from so deaf
we shout out to those guys thank you so
much but to get on with the news these
two new weapons in particular are called
the car SMG and the proto hold beam now
fans of the titanfall series will
recognize the car SMG as it has appeared
in both of the titanfall games and in
this in these games the car sim Jeebs a
little bit of a slower firing SMG they
had a little bit more damage per shot
him much less recoil compared to the
other entries in the game so it's kind
of like the r99 we have in apex legend
except fired a little bit slower and did
a little bit more damage so I'm very
excited to see how the car SMG is gonna
be placed into the game and if it's
gonna be worth it I personally like the
gnar 99 and the r31 carbine so I wonder
if this will be just as good or maybe
even better
I'll have gameplay on screen just the
case of any of you guys don't know how
the car SMG works I'll have from the old
titanfall games with links in the
description to that specific gameplay if
you want to see more the second new
weapon that was leaked is called the
portal hole beam it seems to be a
completely new weapon within titanfall
the titanfall universe this weapons
description claims that the weapons
during energy from robotic targets so
that you can redirect it towards your
enemies and if they are talking about
robots Pathfinder and the loot ticks or
the apex drone guys running around the
map are the only robots within the game
so I don't know how that's gonna work
but with certain leaks talking about
Titans entering apex legends this could
actually be very similar to the charge
rifle from titanfall 1 a and 2 now
personally to me I would def
enjoy this I definitely use the charge
rifle a lot more in terms of anti-titan
weapons I just don't I don't know why
it's just something about the charger if
what was so satisfying to me so I'll
definitely be interested to see how the
charger or four will fit within Apex
Legends if you can use it on people or
if it's most likely going to be more
effective for Titans Titans or even
coming to the game
this is something completely different
and we have no clue what it is yeah guys
let me know your thoughts about both
these weapons in the comments but looks
and I'd love to know what you guys think
about this I'm personally very excited
to play with the car SMG not so much the
charged rifle as much as the car cuz I'm
a big SMG fan and I was like using that
weapon within the map so titanfall just
running around wall writing big as I'm
in here and thoughts on that like the V
if you do enjoy subscribe for new I
cover the informational side of apex
legends that being the balance changes
the hero updates the new legend
balancing the new weapon leaks new items
everything that has to do with apex
legends definitely stay subscribe to the
channel if you want to be kept
up-to-date with everything happening
within the world of that game maybe that
might see more Sousa videos would be on
the screen if you guys do want to check
that out I think I showed above great
dick for watching the video and peace
out
I will go get some more sleep
you
[Music]